[Musique]
alors mon premier voeu c'est évidemment
d'être être vaccinés mais que tout le
monde soit vacciné tous les pays aussi
le risque d'ailleurs c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre de pays qui n'ait pas les
moyens sur la planète d'obtenir des
vaccins alors il faudra faire de ce
point de vue là un gros effort de
solidarité mais véritablement c'est le
seul moyen de retrouver une vie à peu
près une vie à peu près normale
cet ennemi il est complètement invisible
et les clandestins y circulent sans
qu'on s'en aperçoive
le vaccin c'est la seule solution le
deuxième feu est bien c'est que bacon
abate frontière parce que le confinement
et lui elle a peut-être donné l'habitude
où la tentation de se refermer de
s'enfermer sur soi même de considérer
que les ennemis étaient ailleurs donc il
valait mieux dresser des murs et surtout
pour rencontrer des gens différents
ce mélange est un peu parce que tout ça
ces facteurs de progress mon troisième
veux c'est qu'on tombent les masques
enfin on tombent les masques qu'on se
débarrasse de sa lyre vrai et
transparent être solidaire être loyal
être honnête c'est ça de tomber ligne
[Musique]